[Music]
hey my name is Lizzie Mason and I am an
LA NBA dancer and today we're going to
be reviewing a few iconic cheer scenes
and seeing how accurate they are as you
know movies these arms
I don't think high schoolers can say
sexy but okay appropriate for children I
wish there were actually that when you
guys participating in chair in high
school like that would be awesome
there actually are some male
cheerleaders and dancers that have
joined the NFL and then in game this
year it's very good it's very
progressive we hope to see more
Lawrence's hair needs to be in a
ponytail
I feel like if anybody saw that they
would be a little bored it would just be
more of a performance versus like hi
look at us we have arrived we're here
we're ready cheer is all about school
spirit so like it's not about the
individual it's about the school it's
about everyone so then we'd be doing him
a favor
so then they could feel good about
sending Raggedy Ann appear to jacket's
crowd cheers are you talking to BRR it's
cold in here I said there must be some
Toros in the atmosphere I know you
didn't think a white girl made your
service is over as of this moment
stealing chairs a thing it's hard I feel
like it is a thing in high school but
also that there are so many cheers that
sometimes it's hard to really decipher
where it came from originally anyways
there's been so many chairs throughout
generations like sometimes it's really
hard to just like pinpoint like whose it
was first I've never personally
witnessed someone that's stealing
something like very unique like that and
trying to put it on their team but I
mean I'm sure it's possible I'm sure
people do it
with the spirit
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't want it now no it's okay severe
stick doesn't lose anything
the person who drops it however goes
days I mean like I don't know about all
that but there are actual spirit sticks
that teams can earn like during summer
camp they basically just represent the
spirit of your team so the fork lure of
don't drop the spirit stick is basically
like you don't want to let your team
down so you don't let your team spirit
hit the ground
[Music]
the purpose of a coach is to help the
younger generation to guide them to be a
positive role model you know to to point
them in the right direction not to just
tear them down and like to just be evil
like that's just me I never really came
across a an instance where spirit
fingers were a thing only times very
fingers have been a thing is in
reference to this movie and is as like a
joke you know to be like spirit videos
this is actually pretty cool
yes let's go
ending stunt let's go like they're super
clean but like the clovers just had so
much more going on I never realized they
were from they're from San Diego like
they drove all the way up to Compton to
steal their cheers I don't know if it
would be like legal to do that I'm not
really surprised that the clovers wanted
I remember watching this and I was like
I really hope they win because I feel
like the clovers routine just like a lot
more going on you know they were using
the mat a lot more versus the Toros like
they they were very stationary a lot in
one formation you know like the stunts
happening in the bath they weren't using
their space as much that's just in my
opinion Pacific Vista has never had a
fat cheerleader hey Brianna Brittany has
something she wants to tell you no I was
like she looks exactly the same as they
look exactly the same I didn't realize
well lay off the snacks with the extra
workouts the way it should come right
off what if it doesn't put it this way
Pacific vistas never had a fat
cheerleader the culture from my
experience is not like that it's
definitely more uplifting and honestly
like it's not up to your peers to tell
you how you look it's not any one
person's job to pinpoint out somebody
and tell them like that they need to
lose weight like that's not appropriate
whatsoever
cheerleaders come in all different sizes
and it doesn't matter what you look like
all that matters is that you want to
spread school spirit and you want to be
there for your community and you want to
be there for your squad they're just
like clapping every account
every time I like watch like Jared dance
movies I wish there weren't so many like
edits but you can't like fully see the
full picture what's going on you know
like because everything is just edited
together so you can never really tell
like what's actually happening so
they're just like throwing stunts like
just randomly
[Music]
and this clapping every eight count is
like killing me sometimes the clap
happens on the six and it's weird yeah
they were like doing cheer stunts and
cheer movements I mean they were
clapping every four to six counts which
was weird them incorporating krump and
Street movement put them over the edge
there are never really any two teams on
the mat at the same time you know like
doing things cuz that's just very very
unsafe because you never know like who's
gonna go flying across the room ladies
where's the heat where's the sizzle well
you haven't seen our Big Finish yet
[Music]
check your cell by date ladies faux
lesbian kissing has a vinta boo since
1994 I feel like there would be like a
guideline to how the auditions going to
run like there will be a specific cheer
specific dance a specific thing that you
are told to do so like the people who
are judging can see that you can do that
specific thing it wouldn't just be like
show us what you can do well then you
might as well just take everybody
because it's like everyone can do
something
[Music]
[Music]
they like walked away and started
playing the football game like while
they were performing like I would be so
mad like I would be like don't walk away
like I'm still dancing wait till after
I'm done performing and then we'll watch
you play see how that goes like it's a
give-and-take cute that was super cute
so I feel like Riverdale goes more
towards like the dance like the song
palm sorts a type of movement instead of
like traditional chair movement these
movies are great and I'm always
entertained with these and I enjoy them
so much but the relationships between
the peers and the fact that there's no
adults anywhere that's pretty
unrealistic all the cheerleaders and
dancers that I've come across of are
actually very nice people and actually
care about the the sport and the art
that we participate in that's our
purpose of being there is to spread
positivity and to be there for our
community to be positive role models for
the ones coming up behind us
[Music]